hey guys i'm abby Sharpe welcome to
Abby's kitchen today's what I need a
youtuber view is sponsored by ritual and
I'm gonna be reviewing vegan youtuber
Myles Kesari from healthy crazy-cool now
before we get started I want to talk for
a minute about my personal supplement
routine but I get that life does get
kind of crazy and it can become hard to
make sure we're getting all of the
essential nutrients that we need every
day so a lot of people do ask me what
brand of prenatal vitamins I use and I
recently discovered ritual vitamins
which is a vitamin subscription service
that delivers supplements to your door
and it's only about a dollar a day this
is so nice for those of us who are
practicing social distancing or if we
just want a convenient option that we
don't have to remember to always go out
and refill I know the supplement world
is overwhelming but I like rituals
prenatal because it has 12 essential
nutrients to support the health of me
and baby before and during pregnancy
including methylated fourth generation
folate vegan b12 d3 and Omega 3 and they
have no colorants additives or unlisted
ingredients it's also vegan sugar-free
non-gmo gluten-free and allergen free so
if you're having a hard time finding a
vitamin that fits your dietary needs
this really does have it all also if you
find that taking a prenatal can make you
a little bit nauseous these ones have a
no nausea capsule design so you don't
have to take them necessarily with food
you can check out the link in the
description to get 10% off your first
three months on ritual now let's get
into the video
okay so miles is a vegan youtuber with
almost 200,000 YouTube subscribers who
describes himself as the tahini king I
mean just watch a few of his videos and
you'll get what I'm saying about that
actually was Myles who inspired me to
switch up how I do these what I need a
videos to make them a little bit more
inclusive and extensive I assume he
still wouldn't approve especially
because I'm now doing one on him but I
do think this format ensures we make it
more about the diet and what we can
learn from it rather than the person
itself which as you know was never my
goal to begin with so if you're liking
this format definitely
forget to subscribe so that you don't
miss out on any of my upcoming content
now before we get into today's video too
much a gentle reminder that this video
is for education and entertainment
purposes only and is not meant in any
way to diagnose or prescribe any way of
eating so you should always speak to a
registered dietician or doctor about
your specific needs
okay so you heard about my settlements
let's kick things off by looking at his
yeah I take the immediate three just as
kind of a good balance and the b12
because I'm vegan and like I've said
before if you're a vegan it doesn't take
b12 you're not just a vegan you're a
[ __ ]
oh my god so I kind of love this guy
already but yes I'm happy to hear that
he's promoting taking your vitamin d3
and b12 and omega-3 really what I think
would be the most important vitamins for
any plant-based person but also for most
omnivores as well so let's see what
we're having for breakfast on day one
alrighty so here's my Brett Rosen's
brunch lunch
I don't even know what to call it I'm
gonna give it a little sprinkle of hemp
seeds for extra crunch some Omega threes
extra protein you guys know I put hemp
seeds on absolutely everything whether
it's sweet or savory a pop of sherry
because so yeah this half is the potato
salad I also forgot to tell you
obviously I put in salt and pepper not
about to make any kind of meal without
salt and pepper and don't understand
these salt free people it's just [ __ ]
crazy
I saved back some of the steamed greens
just to have extra Greenidge extra
greens on the side now this is a very
creamy potato salad because obviously
you've got the nutty earthy beautiful
tahini liquid gold but it's also very
tangy and pungent from the dill and the
lemon and all of the other flavors and
you get the crunch from the celery it's
just perfect okay so that looks super
delish
I think we're kindred spirits in that we
both put hemp hearts on everything but I
mean if we really want to talk balance
we could add a little more protein in
this maybe throw in some silken tofu in
the dressing or serve it with a side of
seared tofu but at least we're getting a
little from the hemp and
tahini I also have to say I love how
Myles describes food between his ode to
Sharon fruit earlier on in the video and
then just the way he's talking and
walking us through this meal he really
gets the sensuality of food and even
something as humble as a potato salad
sounds so incredible when he describes
it let's take a look at day two whenever
I do have like regular coffee which is
like not regularly I actually don't feel
like it gives me energy I feel like it
makes me anxious for 20 minutes and then
I just feel tired so again I don't drink
coffee for energy I good food for energy
yes oh my gosh I see so many youtubers
who buzz through the day just sipping
their green tea lattes and energy drinks
and it's really refreshing to hear
someone say hey I didn't coffee because
I like the flavor and I eat food with
calories
aka energy for energy all right let's
see what he's gonna eat some frozen
brews love myself some frozen blue
specially on hot food like the contrast
between the hot squishy potatoes then
you get like the icy crunch a little bit
of tartness from the frozen berries love
it now it is my duty as the one and only
nut butter king to smother this with
some good runny and kind of clumpy today
almond butter almond butter you can of
course use any nut butter you have lying
around you can use peanut butter you can
use cashew butter you can also use
tahini or sunflower seed butter if you
don't do nuts
or if you're allergic to nuts this is
one of the things in fact the main thing
that I find makes my meals are lot more
filling and satiating it just keeps me
full up and satisfied is adding a good
amount of fat and protein to my meals
and obviously almond butter is a great
source of fat and protein very high in
protein for a knot and to be honest it's
just delicious so this is curry Oh
coconut yogurt which is very thick and
creamy I love it's the best coat
and yeah what I did to make this yogurt
yogurt higher in protein
I added half a scoop of the Madagascan
vanilla viva life protein powder and not
only does that make the meal a lot more
satisfying because again we bumped up
the protein but it bumps up the flavor
as well because that vanilla flavor also
going to add a sprinkle of hemp seeds
you guys know I put hemp seeds on
absolutely everything in the last 15
minutes trying to make this look
Instagram herbal but clearly I failed
Cheers
oh my gosh that looks awesome and I love
that he talks about the importance of
adding a good amount of fat and protein
to meals to boost up satiety I love this
guy I mean he may kind of hate me but I
think he's a lot like me but in a cute
British man for him let's take a look at
day three so yeah I don't normally have
a bow toast for breakfast I'm getting
back onto like savory breakfasts like I
think I said in my last white in a day
that like when I was in Bali I guys I
ate more fruit than freely like you have
no idea and I'd love to start with fruit
right but the thing is it just it just
opens up a black hole and I don't know
it's just a thing but I'm really getting
back onto savory breakfasts and just
really loving avocado toast
that looks so good that it hurts my soul
not to be eating it right now
I am also obsessed with sourdough
anything and that's a nice generous
portion of some delicious looking
sourdough avocado toast now also I'm
happy to hear that he's switching up his
breakfast and not just having fruit I'm
not really sure exactly what he means by
a black hole situation may be that the
fruit kind of goes right through him and
it gives him the runs or that it leaves
him like super hungry soon after either
way I am happy to see a more substantial
breakfast with some more slow-burning
carbs and healthy fats in here with the
avocado and of course that beautiful
sourdough bread I mean if he wanted he
could use my technique of mashing some
white beans into his avvocato to boost
up the protein but I get not everyone is
crazy about having a lot of protein in
the morning and this is a huge step up
in my opinion from just having fruit
okay now let's talk about my overall
thoughts on breakfast all of these are
crazy delicious looking breakfast he
definite
the carb lover in the morning so with
the exception of day two we could
definitely boost up the protein a little
bit for better satiety which I know is
really important for miles but hey this
is why we look at the entire day and if
he's gonna pick it up on the protein
later on in the day I am 100% cool with
a high carb morning I mean that is when
most of us actually need a little energy
kick and I really appreciate that Myles
relies on food not just caffeine to get
that fix let's take a look at meal 2 the
base of this is two large heads of
romaine yes this is a giant bowl we all
know I love my romaine that refreshing
crunch and then we got the crispy tofu
soft avocado the spicy kimchi lots of
crunchy pine nuts yes I mean it's a very
simple salad yes full of goodness
proteins healthy fats kimchi so good for
your gut lots of greens but the best
part let's douse it in some of the
dressing and honestly this dressing has
come out absolutely perfect actually the
first time that I tried it but it's born
so I leave the full exact measurements
that I use down below this also looks
incredible
I love that we have some protein in the
tofu healthy fats in the avocado nuts
and of course tahini and the added
probiotic benefits of kimchi in there
not a lot of carbs going on and that is
totally actually cool considering he had
a super higher carb meal at breakfast or
brunch or whatever he wants to call it
that day so this is why you kind of have
to look at the entire day as a whole
taken together we are definitely
covering all of our bases with this
awesome looking meal let's take a look
at day two and a whole large cucumber
gonna toss the potatoes and the tofu
with this little refreshing mix and then
we've got the green sauce for the top
and you all know you should all know the
cameras going to be I don't care that
when I eat lunch another one of my big
tips for people that are just always
hungry is to eat a lot of fiber a lot of
firepower veggies a lot of greens I
would usually always with my lunch and
my dinners on
eat like a lot of romaine lettuce
spinach kale maybe some steamed broccoli
or green beans lots of fibrous greens to
kind of bulk up the meal okay so like
his other lunch this looks amazing
I would kill for this right now and I
love the combination of kind of hot and
cold and creamy and refreshing we've got
lots of fiber in the veggies and the
fruit we got fat in the dressing in the
avocado and protein from the tofu and I
agree everything is more delicious in
some kind of taco vessel so that looks
super bomb let's take a look at day
three all right here's the final result
this tofu is just so perfectly crispy
and then these broccoli broccolini
whoever is these florets are so nice and
caramelized and that's because of the
coconut aminos
I often roast in bus a mikvah Nagar or
balsamic glaze as well if I want things
to get like really sweet and caramelized
but coconut aminos does the job even
better then I've just got some purple
cabbage as per use and underneath
remember that huge bowl of kale I showed
you which is in one of my shoot like
huge huge balls they all wilted down
kind of cooked down but became nice and
tender
just through the process of massaging it
with the avocado the coconut aminos and
the lime juice all it needs of course is
a good drizzle of liquid gold another
killer lunch
I mean we've got loads of beautiful
colorful vegetables we've got our
protein and the tofu healthy fats from
the avocado olive oil and tahini lots of
great things going on and it looks
insanely good also I just picked up a
new tip I never thought to roast with
coconut aminos so yeah thanks miles I'm
totally gonna be checking that out let
me give you my thoughts on his lunches
so miles honey can you invite me to
lunch sometime because I want what you
are having now I am so happy to see a
little bit more protein action happening
with a second meal it is becoming clear
to me that Myles may not know that he's
doing this but he's actually really well
balancing out his day night
with carbs and protein I mean it is a
bit repetitive as he tends to rely
mainly on tahini for fat tofu for
protein and potatoes for carbs but I get
that sometimes you just like what you
like I am happy to see him switching up
his preparation of the ingredients and
serving them all into interesting and
delicious looking meals let's take a
look at his snacks I'm impressed
it does smell like orange Nutella man I
love chocolate orange I miss Terry's
chocolate orange so much Cheers
this is the kind of thing like even if
you cracked her open on date night like
you just would not share I am dying
I love that he has an erect penis over
this chocolate orange peanut butter even
though I admittedly do not like the
combination of orange and chocolate and
I think Terry's chocolate orange is just
gross but I get that it's totally a love
or hate a thing and if you have a strong
opinion on this like me or like Myles
please leave me a comment below about
where you stand
are you team chocolate orange or not I
totally want to know let's take a look
at date two some good old cell do you
know what guys I reckon this is actually
gonna be born I have a feeling Cheers
balls on top of that so I love that
miles reviews different nourishing
satiating snacks and macadamia nuts are
rich in healthy fats manganese and fiber
as well as tons of flavonoid
antioxidants plus they taste legit
amazing and are for sure at one of my
favorites so I am confident without even
trying it that that macadamia nut butter
would be so good let's take a look at
day three I'm so excited to see all
these different nut butter spreads
I mean Choice buys peanut butter it does
sound kind of weird but with this brand
you just never want to write them off
and also I don't have any celery today
which is kind of criminal so instead we
are going in with a cohort Cheers
jeez the flavors in this all I can say
about this
oh my gosh it's like Christmas but
spreadable I feel like I need this now I
am obsessed with chai so hey Nora tea if
you want to ship up to Canada please hit
me up also says that he has an apple
after that which I think would be really
tasty with the chai peanut butter so
that would be a nice duo if he wanted to
combine the two
let me tell you my overall thoughts on
his snacks okay so you guys know my
thoughts on a healthy snack I always try
to look for one or more of what I call
the hunger crushing combinations so
that's fiber protein and healthy fats
well even though all of these snacks are
basically the same they are nut butter I
have to say they all fit that criteria
perfectly nuts in general are a perfect
package snack because they have
plant-based protein fiber for regularity
in heart health and those awesome
monounsaturated fats also I need to try
this brand because these nut butters
would be so delicious and so fun in
oatmeal yogurt or pancakes I could think
of so many great recipes to make with
them alright let's talk about dinner
called oh and Marmite on toast and a
protein shake so I'm gonna show you what
I on another evening this week instead
as it's much more exciting the best
vegan pizza I've ever had in my life
okay so miles actually had avocado toast
with Marmite and a protein shake for
dinner but he instead shows us a super
yummy that he had another night which
looks awesome by the way
but the truth is there's nothing wrong
with the boring meal he actually had I
like that we have some healthy fats from
the avocado cars from the toast and
protein in the protein shake I mean even
if it's not fancy or Instagram evil or
u2 beable in this case I like that he
still has a good balance of macros
sometimes I just really liked the
realness of hey I was alone tonight and
didn't feel like a laborat fancy meal so
this is what hit the spot I mean there
are lots of nights where I eat like
rique yogurt and oatmeal and I'm okay
with that let's take a look at day two
which isn't a vegan place but they do
have a new vegan menu and what they were
to be honest but it was bomb and when I
say bomb I mean that the heat from the
spices almost blew my head off chickpea
flour dumplings this pancake potato dosa
thing which was super tasty and also
these little shots of spiced carrot soup
I had these pancake wraps which were
filled with vegan cheese quinoa lots of
different veggies and to be honest I
have no idea what else was in there oh I
am totally craving Indian right now that
looks like an amazing feast I love that
unlike a lot of youtubers miles is not
afraid of eating out and it doesn't seem
to impact his diet earlier on the day
like we sometimes see by that I mean he
doesn't restrict calories or portions to
save calories for a big binge later
considering some of the youtubers that
I've reviewed recently I really
appreciate that what this tells me is
that even though miles may say he isn't
really able to eat intuitively which
I'll talk about soon I actually think he
may have greater skills than he thinks
and can respond to his hunger cues enjoy
food be social and not punish himself
for it later I am not seeing this
extreme restrict binge situation that I
see with so many other wellness
youtubers let's take a look at day three
or quinoa and black bean burgers which
come with the most amazing caramelized
onions we also got some salad because
you can never eat dinner without greens
in my opinion and also this really
amazing creamy coleslaw
so we went to the best vegan ice cream
place in London called Eureka anyways
after being one of those annoying people
who asks to try every flavor I got a
scoop of coffee and a scoop of coconut
so lots of delicious looking stuff going
on here I love first of all that he said
you know you can't eat dinner without
greens honey you are basically an
honorary dietitian in my books second I
am also that annoying person who samples
every single ice cream I mean how can
you possibly commit if you do not try
and finally I love that he said to
nourish your body but also your soul
miles I get you now let's talk about my
overall thoughts on his dinners so a lot
of you might be thinking well what he's
eating for dinner isn't very healthy how
could a be possibly approve this is
actually a breath of fresh air to me in
this perfect obsessive vegan youtube
diet world folks when you're eating this
many beautiful colorful vegetables slow
burning carbohydrates plant-based
proteins and healthy fats for breakfast
lunch and your snacks you're gonna hate
your nutrient needs so there is no need
to sweat it out if you dine out for that
you know every other meal once in a
while if that is what brings you joy I
actually like that Myles gives us a
realistic look at what a balanced normal
relaxed vegan diet could look like
and since Myles discusses his needs to
keep close tabs on its macros and
calories sometimes I think it's great to
see him kind of loosen the reins a bit
to dine out and enjoy that time with
friends
so is this diet balanced I would
absolutely say yes I'm actually seeing a
really nice macronutrient distribution
between Myles days as well as a solid
sense of flexibility in his lifestyle
which is really refreshing in the
youtube vegan community if he opts for a
carb heavy breakfast his lunch tends to
be higher in protein and fat with a
solid variety of fresh fruits and
vegetables enjoyed throughout he's also
not explicitly demonizing any
ingredients and isn't afraid to enjoy a
social meal with friends without it
fueling some kind of restricted binge
cycle Myles you are a cool guy now is
there anything missing in his diet I
don't really think so I mean he is
taking his b12 D and Omega threes and
his meals are impossibly healthy-looking
so folks if you want some vegan
inspiration you know where to look now I
also want to touch on some awesome
things that I think we can definitely
take away from Myles this channel first
of all he's not afraid of oil so there
have been a lot of youtubers that I've
reviewed lately that are explicitly
avoiding oils
I've done a whole video on this looking
at the research for and against that
argument so definitely checked it out
right here but I am happy to see miles
have a smart yet not obsessive approach
to added oils sometimes like for the
dressing he made with tahini he doesn't
use oil because the fat from the tahini
is enough to build body and carry the
rest of the ingredients and sometimes
like when he's roasting vegetables and
tofu he uses enough to coat the
vegetables and ingredients so that they
crisp up and get nice and brown this in
my books is a smart use of oil I too
don't like a really oily salad dressing
that's a personal thing but I do pan
sear or roast with oil because otherwise
you just never gets that rich
caramelized flavor and color that we're
looking for when we roast foods so I
would say that this is a really smart
use of oil in my books and definitely
something that others could look towards
number two he gives some great tips on
how to build a satisfying meal
physically and emotionally in several of
his videos Myles discusses that he has a
seemingly insatiable appetite but what
he has learned from trial and error is
that there are a few things that make
his food more satisfying he specifically
aims to make sure that there's good
protein good carbs and good fat
basically echoing what I said about the
hunger crushing combination and you can
see that apparent in his food choices
which is great but he also talks about
the meal components that are not
nutritionally based so the color the
crunch the variety the flavor what he's
talking about is emotional satisfaction
in that something could be straight-up
super satiating physically but if it's
not appealing emotionally you'll still
go searching for something else
something more so kudos for actually
breaking down both elements that go into
building our true satisfaction number
three he doesn't judge people based on
their dietary choices it's kind of
really disappointing to be very honest
the amount of comments I've gotten
recently about like you know one of my
very close friends who you're gonna see
in this video like oh my god are you
still friends with her you know she's
not
vegan anymore how can you hang out with
someone like that and it's like I can't
believe there are people in this world
that love people just for what they put
in their mouth like I'm telling you
right now none of my friends none of my
friends are my friends because we're
just vegan it's really sad that there
are still people in this world who kind
of have that division of who they hang
out with based on what they send down
the chute it makes me really sad and the
fact that I've got so many comments
about this one person saying oh my god
like are you still friends with her are
you still gonna hang out with her
because she's not vegan and it's like
number one offended that you would even
assume or question that I'm that shallow
and number two like get some help
yes but can we get more vegans like you
and fewer vegans like freely in this
world please but honestly we're all just
trying our best here and figuring out
what is good to eat is such a personal
choice so I love that Myles doesn't
discriminate against friends of his who
maybe don't share his same food
philosophies honestly I don't care what
your dietary beliefs are these are the
kind of friends I want in my life
number four his recipes just look
amazing I mean this is really a big
enough reason to watch Myles I think his
recipes are delicious looking and simple
and I would happily eat anything he
makes and would love to go out for a
meal with him because the guy totally
knows how to order now are there any
problematic claims being made by Myles I
mean I don't hear anything that I would
flag us perpetuating misinformation
I actually think miles is super
thoughtful about the information he
shares and the language that he uses in
fact there was one point where he kind
of nonchalantly says the word junk food
and then in his edit he clarifies what
he meant by that so that he wouldn't
offend anyone I mean I get you Myles it
is really hard to be an influencer these
days and I am NOT going to judge you for
saying junk food
I'm just happy that you're so purposeful
about the information that you would put
out there into the world so thank you
for that now I do think it's important
to address some of miles as thoughts on
intuitive eating to clear a few things
up so miles recently made a video called
being on a diet is okay intuitive eating
is dangerous for some of us including me
I'm just going to dive in and respond to
a few of the points he makes because
intuitive eating even though I agree
with a lot of the principles behind it
it doesn't work for everyone so miles
were actually not that different you
know I have constantly clarified based
on my own learning that intuitive may
not be for everyone in fact I mentioned
this at the beginning of every intuitive
eating video that I produce I also tell
people that we can kind of choose what
aspects of intuitive eating works for us
but I do believe that at least some of
the principles apply to all of us namely
things like respecting our body gentle
nutrition discovering the satisfaction
factor coping with your emotions with
kindness etc but there are a lot of
flaws in the intuitive eating model if
followed by the book specifically that
it doesn't account for all pre-existing
health care concerns and also
socioeconomic status let's see what else
he has to say but there's a big
difference there's a big difference
between someone that is severely
orthorexia
very obsessed with food and will only
eat certain things at certain times the
versus someone that is conscious and
mindful and knows what is best for their
body therefore plans their meals
accordingly and wisely and intelligently
and I don't have a fourth word but you
know what I mean 100% and this is
actually baked into the intuitive eating
model but I get how miles is unsure of
this as intuitive eating has kind of
being positioned by a lot of critics as
just eat whatever you want whenever you
want donuts all day Air day there is
Ashley still a consideration for
nutrition worked into this way of eating
not only through one of the principles
in itself which I'll speak more about in
a moment but because planning your meals
and being thoughtful about
meals is a really great way to keep your
hunger and fullness managed in a way
that feels good
so for example if I don't plan my lunch
out it's not the end of the world but it
may mean I let myself getting more
hungry than I comfortably would
otherwise and then I have to make more
frantic decisions about what to eat
once it gets to that uncomfortable state
this is what intuitive eating is really
trying to prevent but in the most
compassionate non-judgmental way
possible so if I eat more one day
because I didn't plan oh well you know
I'll Bank the information for next time
and I'll move along let's see what else
he has to say with an intuitive eating
it's kind of all against you know no
calorie counting there's no time a place
for calorie counting you know the
emphasis should not be on weight loss
and in my opinion this is bollocks if
you are severely overweight yes the
emphasis should be on weight loss for
your health drastic action needs to be
taken when your health is in addressed a
drastic position you know okay so here's
where I stand on this there may be
intuitive eating practitioners who say
this is the protocol for everyone
regardless of your current health status
or goals but personally I do believe
that it requires an individualized
approach not everyone can follow all of
the principles in order and feel
comfortable giving themselves that
freedom to eat ad libitum when they
don't really have proper hunger or
fullness cues or when their health is
currently in a concerning place as for
as comment about eating yourself to 300
pounds what I will say is that like
hunger cues for miles
sometimes fullness sensations are also
complicated and cloudy for some people
one thing I would be curious about is
whether or not the food choices of
someone like who miles is referencing
are both stating physically and
satisfying psychologically when these
things are constantly at odds overeating
is way more likely to occur so for
example maybe we're using food as a
coping mechanism and relying a lot on
refined carbohydrates that are really
tasty but not fueling our body with the
protein healthy fats or fiber than it
needs to feel satiated and energized so
personally I believe that some people
may need to work with a dietician who
can help build out some structure to get
those hunger and fullness cues back help
on understand their emotional eating and
mouth eating cues educate on the types
of food that are both satisfying and
safe shading and ultimately encourage
the client to trust their body in the
baby steps that they're really
comfortable with there's also an
interesting kind of disclaimer here he's
got
[Music]
okay so I think like a lot of people who
criticize intuitive eating I'm not sure
miles has actually read the book in its
entirety and notice that there's a whole
principle on nutrition of course
intuitive eating may not be as much of a
numbers game as other diets but it
doesn't make it a free-for-all eating
fest in fact in my experience a lot of
the people who feel really relaxed about
intuitive eating do you have a solid
knowledge of nutrition the difference
however between somebody who feels
comfortable with intuitive eating who
has this nutrition knowledge and someone
who ends up in ortho x''k territory is
that they don't punish themselves for
this knowledge now I want to flag that
the reason why nutrition is left until
some of the foundational principles are
ironed out is that when you're stuck in
restriction mode any choices based on
nutrition are still coming from a place
of restriction that is just not
sustainable so once you work through the
process of letting go of the diet voice
in your head you can make decisions
about what to eat that not only take
into account what looks good or a tastes
good but what feels good to your body
and honors your health and nutritional
needs being on a diet be on a healthy
diet is a good thing and also the word
again the word diet can be taken in so
many different ways because when we hear
the word diet we think of restriction
lack of calories severe weight loss but
it actually when I think of the word
diet it means just a way of eating that
either supports or damages your health
it's essentially a lifestyle I think the
most important point I want to make in
this video is that for certain people
like me it is absolutely impossible to
intuitive eat
long term maybe in the future I can do
it right but as someone that has
stretched my stomach to the absolute max
by just binging on like I can't even
explain how much food like back in the
day as someone that went through periods
of starvation as someone that went
through periods of massively
over-exercising I'm talking like three
four hours a day in the gym you know as
someone that has formerly been addicted
to drugs I know this video is gonna get
Dee monetized for me saying
word but I'm just being real here as
someone that has been on so many
different medications for my physical
health problem for those of you they
don't know I have I have I had a disease
of high adrenaline it's very rare it's
called pheochromocytoma okay so I think
it's worth mentioning that while I do
believe everyone can incorporate at
least some of the principles of
intuitive eating like I mentioned not
everyone's eating and food history or
even their current medication or health
status allows them to just jump in
unassisted some people need to be guided
a bit with some support by a dietician
with structured meals and snacks about
four or five a day until you can get
that hunger and fullness sensitivity
back and if you're currently on
medication that blunts those cues then
you may actually need to continually and
mindfully eat those consistent meals to
make sure your body is getting enough
nutrition this is something I definitely
think a dietician can help people with
but it looks to me like miles is doing
exactly just that on his own he knows
his body's needs and has a good base
knowledge on nutrition and he's
nourishing himself accordingly
even if his medical history prevents him
from feeling those regular hunger cues
very well so some people will just not
easily ever feel comfortable eating
intuitively for a variety of reasons not
just medication you know it's not a
perfect foolproof model but that does
not mean that miles can't incorporate at
least some of these principles and like
I said I actually think he's doing a
great job of that I know for a fact that
when my anxiety is very very high it
makes me feel physically sick
it makes me feel like I can't even look
at food and on those days I have to be
conscious and wise and if it gets to 1
p.m. 2 p.m. I'm still not hungry I have
to be like okay I know my body is on
some kind of roller coaster right now
but I need to eat because if I don't I'm
gonna spiral down further and again
essentially that goes against intuitive
eating because my body is telling me not
to eat yeah I know I need to after years
and years of a
abuse my body deserves this and if I
were to intuitive eat I'd be lost okay
so this is another common concern
amongst a lot of people when it comes to
intuitive eating but intuitive eating is
not just about listening and responding
to hunger cues it's also about self-care
and gentle nutrition and it sounds like
miles actually has a really good sense
that if he just lets his hunger guide
him he won't eat enough and he knows
that
so using that knowledge he's choosing to
nourish his body because he knows it
will make him feel emotionally and
physically better if he does like I said
earlier intuitive eating is ultimately a
bit of a privileged concept and it
doesn't account very well for food
insecurity and illness which is what
miles seems to be describing here so as
I mentioned in my updated view post on
intuitive eating and health at every
size I don't believe you're doing
anything wrong if you can't follow each
of the principles of intuitive eating to
a tee this process can really meet you
where you are and we can learn how to
integrate the principles and components
that work for each of us and I'll not
note folks that is all from me today a
big thank you again to ritual for
sponsoring this video so you can check
out the link in the description ritual
calm / sharp 10 and use my promo code
sharp 10 to get 10% off your first three
months on ritual if you liked it be sure
to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with your thoughts on any
youtubers that you want me to review
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]